how do you feel about your parents being
your teachers right now how's that oh I
get to learn a lot from them and I'm at
my own pace but they're also pretty
strict because my mom used to be a
teacher oh so you have real teachers not
like oh hi Ryan it's so nice to meet you
guys Stella Stella and I have definitely
watched many hours of Brian's work oh
wow real excited to get to talk to you
guys today you know we've been watching
your videos for a long time and we just
have so many questions about how you
make that so do you remember I know
you've been making videos since you were
about five years old do you remember
making some of your first videos uh yes
I remember my first video I think oh
really what was your very first Lego
train
let me just took me to the store and
then she wanted me to like yeah pick
anything and I picked the Lego train and
we built it okay watch what you want
today what toy you want today what is
your pick of the week it's a Lego
choo-choo train I like a Tudor train and
then an empire was born never see that
coming so how do you guys choose which
toys you want to unbox Brian what's your
what's your favorite stuff done box how
do you pick it hmm I think it's just by
like how cool it looks and maybe I could
try to guess what's inside of it ooh you
like toys like that where you guess
what's inside so right now we're all
obviously at home and you know you guys
do a lot of your work at home because
you're opening toys and playing at home
but now the were stuck here Ryan your
parents are also your teachers huh how
do you feel about your parents being
your teachers right now how's that all I
get to learn a lot from them
and I'm at my own pace but they're also
pretty strict because my mom used to be
a teacher oh so you have real teachers
not like and I just finished my
multiplication and now I'm doing
division wow that's very advanced math
division we're having a very different
experience of homeschooling here we're
rookies we're figuring it out how do you
like us being your teachers do you miss
school
Stella really misses going to school
because I can't really see my friends as
much but at least we can still see each
other on like video chat or online games
that's true that's what we're doing too
right see everybody's doing the same
thing so not only do you guys have an
incredible YouTube channel channels
multiple channels now right you have a
show on Nickelodeon
Ryan's mystery playdate what does it
like to have a show on Nickelodeon it's
very fun cuz instead of just doing
videos we can do like a bunch of other
stuff on there like we have a bunch of
challenges we can also guess who the
play date is it's really different
because drink when we film videos
together it's just you know me and Ryan
or just the three of us or a family so
it's like you know having just his mom
filming him usually behind one camera
but like I might as mystery play date
you like that
he gets experience something that he you
know like a normal kid usually doesn't
get to experience so having a whole
camera crew and people learning to work
together like a this usually it's like a
t crew members just to create an episode
and there's like multiple different
cameras and we have to learn which
camera to look at you know when we say
this and then when our next line which
camera to look for the next part I
eventually wanted to be a comedian like
a professional comedian in the future so
we thought it'd be a good experience for
him to really experience the filming
expanse of the TV crew so since you guys
are spending so much time at home like
we all are what are some of your
favorite things to do right now while
we're staying safe at home from the bug
that's like trying to knock you over we
roll deep I'm sure people ask you this
all the time - Ryan I bet it's really
hard to pick but do you have a favorite
toy or what's your favorite toy right
now that's very hard Mormon
video games now huh yeah I guess my
favorite like just any toy yeah anything
[Music]
mm-hmm maybe like one of my surprise
eggs that's definitely a favorite in our
house any surprise going hmm you know
what my favorite surprise too is so tell
us about your quarantine playlists stay
home stay happy right so we made 14
video playlists collectible of the stay
at home activities the kids can do at
home
like a DIY crafting or our projects or
science experiment we thought kids are
staying home right now with parents and
not being able to see their grandparents
or friends so we thought we should post
a series of videos with the fun
activities that they can do at home it's
been very helpful I'm sure it's for us
for so many parents because we're really
looking for stuff to do because because
there's you know a lot of hours in the
day and a lot less available activities
for us so it's it's been awesome and to
us include that the Q&A session with
Annie Slavit yeah on our Ryan's world
channel we made an informative video
about coping 19 for kids so we ask
questions to nd stop it who is the
acting administrator for the center of
Medicare and Medicaid Services so we
felt like adults are well informed about
current pandemic situation but kids are
still confused by Cobie 19 so we ask
questions the kids have to Andy like
some of the questions are like how come
we can't see our friends and
grandparents or how come we have to wash
our hands often or hot what can we do to
stop this
virus from spreading yeah it's it's so
important the way we talk to kids about
it so it's it's so helpful that you guys
are doing that for so many parents
because it's very complicated and being
able to explain things in the clear
concise way that's not scary is you know
I think the most important thing we can
do and you guys have been doing such an
amazing job and supporting your
community and have you been supporting
some really amazing charitable
organizations during this time can you
tell us a little bit about some of those
initiatives you guys are working on as a
gesture of appreciation we made a
donation to this organization called
first responders Children's Foundation
they support the family of actually pend
paramedics police officers firefighters
and all the medical professionals so
they provide like n95 mass to them and
then they also provide hospital stays to
the first responder cuz you know during
this time as some of them are afraid to
go home
and they might infect their family thank
you guys for all that you're doing to
for your community and for so many
communities across the country because
there are obviously you know essential
workers everywhere that need that
support so that's awesome what you guys
are doing